dead inside is something people these
days often use to describe themselves
but for 24 year old Akira he embodies
that phrase completely broken by the
mundane Life as a cog in the stressful
machine that's the Japanese work system
he looks to just waste his life away if
only there could be an event to give
some spice in his life right well that
which becomes a reality when he Bears
witness to his landlord eating another
tenant
turns out the entire city is teeming
with zombies and while it's not exactly
the ideal situation for a person like
Akira is the type of thrill that makes
him feel even more alive than before the
race against doomsday begins with him
looking to finish up his bucket list of
things to do Zone 100 looks to be one of
those knee shits featuring a character
relatable to a sizable chunk of the
anime consuming audience and while
setting the auto keeper surprised it's a
good blend of comedy and flashiness to
get people hooked on this insane ride
and it could very well be the Hidden Gem
of the season